Harry: From calorie count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Pringles in the UK and the US.
This is "Food Wars."
In the UK, our smallest Pringle size
is a 40-gram tube.
These come as a single tube,
as a box of 12,
or, around the holidays,
we can get a Pringles Christmas cracker,
which comes with four 40-gram tubes.
In the US, the smallest
portion of Pringles you can get
is this, a snack stack.
This 19-gram snack stack comes in units of
12, 18,
this is super weird, 27,
and
[grunts]
48 snack stacks.
Our next size is a 70-gram tube.
We also have Pringles in
this grab-and-go size,
which is 2.5 ounces, or 71 grams.
You can get them in single, obviously,
or in packs of 15.
This isn't even the biggest
grab-and-go size, apparently.
They have a size that's even bigger,
that's 74 grams, or 2.5 ounces.
Uh, I ate that on the way here.
I'm sorry.
And then from there we
go to a full-sized tube,
which is 200 grams.
All flavors weigh the
same amount in the UK.
In the US, our regular
tubes are actually small.
You get about 5.5 ounces per tube,
but the flavor actually
adds to the weight.
Here's an original Pringles,
and this is only 5.2 ounces. Huh.
0.3.
0.3 more for the flavor.
But the UK stops at the regular.
Not here in the US.
Check it out.
The party tube. [laughs]
6.8 ounces of chip right there.
Seeing as the weights are so similar,
we're going to count how many Pringles
are in a UK regular tube
versus a US party-stack tube
to see who's getting more.
All right, let's do it.
Oh, yeah.
Harry: Yeah, definitely
gonna need a bigger tray.
I might have to go onto the table.
This is going to be boring.
Pringles, they don't break as easily.
Oh!
I have regularly eaten
a whole tube of Pringles by myself.
Ah!
Quack.
What, where? Here?
Conner: A little down.
Joe: This one?
I'm going to eat them all
instead of putting them back in the tube.
Joe: It's taking all my willpower
not to snack on these as I'm doing it.
Laura: Most people can't then
swallow the whole thing.
Most people aren't me.
[laughs]
I'm not most people, Laura.
Party stack holds roughly 104 Pringles.
So, it looks like a regular tube in the UK
contains around 92 Pringles.
How many can I get in my mouth at once?
That's what I want to know.
Without, like, crunching them
all up and breaking them.
I'm gonna see if I can do 10.
9.
10 Pringles.
I'm going for 13. Lucky 13!
Ah, ah, ah, ah!
Uh-uh.
I'm gonna take two off.
[production crew laughing]
I do not have the mouth
for Pringles, apparently.
My proverbial hat off to you.
The crown is yours.
This right here is roughly 100 grams
of original salted Pringles chips.
In the US, it contains the following:
535 calories,
32.13 grams of fat,
535.5 milligrams of sodium,
and 57.12 grams of carbs.
I know you can't tell,
but this is, like, two-thirds
of the tube, right?
And it contains almost half
of your fat allowance for the day.
100 grams of original Pringles
in the UK contains the following:
514 calories,
33 grams of fat,
520 milligrams of sodium,
and 51 grams of carbs.
That means our Pringles
have slightly more fat
than the US version,
but almost half the saturated fat.
In the US, a majority
of the Pringle flavors
have the same number of
calories as the original flavor,
but there are some changes
to some of the other
numbers when you branch out.
Our saltiest Pringle is
actually the salt and vinegar.
100 grams of UK salt and vinegar
is 40% of your daily allowance of sodium.
The saltiest Pringles in the US
are the Buffalo ranch.
100 grams of them contain
999.6 milligrams of sodium.
Avoid! Avoid!
What in the good God?!
Oh, man!
I can't believe the
flavor in these things.
I gotta try that again.
Oh, my God.
These are so disgusting.
This might be the worst thing
I've tasted on this show.
All the salt for all the
Buffalo ranch in the factory
got condensed into one
container on accident,
and we bought it.
This is so gross.
In the UK, original Pringles
contain the following:
dehydrated potatoes,
vegetable oils (sunflower and corn),
rice flour, wheat starch, corn flour,
emulsifier (E471), maltodextrin,
salt, yeast extract,
yeast powder, and color (annatto).
Original Pringles in the US contain
dried potatoes; vegetable oil,
which is corn, cottonseed,
high oleic soybean oil
and/or sunflower oil;
degerminated yellow
corn flour; cornstarch;
rice flour; maltodextrin;
mono- and diglycerides;
salt; and wheat starch.
These are actually very similar.
The E471 in the UK is actually the same
as the mono- and
diglycerides used in the US,
just used by a different name.
The only other notable changes
are the yeast used in the UK
and the fact that the
UK colors its Pringles
with annatto, an orange-red food color.
But how much different is the color?
OK.
The longest ingredient list
for a classic Pringles flavor
in the UK is prawn cocktail.
It contains 28 main ingredients,
likely with a lot more
because some of them
aren't fully disclosed,
like the flavorings and the spices.
Now, from what I can tell,
the longest ingredients
list for a classic US flavor
is the cheddar and sour cream.
They contain 32 main ingredients.
Along with a bunch of subingredients,
takes the total to 40.
I'm not reading this out loud.
On that list you'll see, of course,
a couple of ingredients
that you won't find
in the UK Pringles,
namely Yellow No. 5 and Yellow No. 6.
I'm wearing Yellow No. 7.
It's always with the yellow stuff.
These are also referred to as
tartrazine and Sunset Yellow.
They were two chemicals highlighted
by a study back in 2007
into links between hyperactivity
and food additives.
The initial results suggested that
there was indeed a link
between these chemicals and hyperactivity.
However, since then, the
European Food Safety Authority
has backtracked and said
that might not be the case.
Also in that study was
Red 40, aka Allura Red,
which appears in the ingredients list
for the Memphis barbecue Pringles
and these, the pizza Pringles.
Foods using these chemicals in the UK
must still bear a warning to say that
they "May have an adverse effect
on activity and attention in children,"
which means that most manufacturers
will just avoid using them.
Wait, has he always been bald?
Yeah, he's bald. Thought he had hair.
Conner: I always thought he wore a top hat,
for whatever reason.
No, you're thinking of the
guy from the Monopoly thing.
No, wait, look! Yeah! Hair.
What the hell?
Hair and no hair.
Julius Pringle!
What's going on, dude?
Is this weird? This is weird, right?
Hairgate 2021.
Why does he have hair in some
and not on the other ones?
Here are all the Pringles
you'll find in the UK,
but not the US.
These are most of the
US-exclusive Pringles.
Cheddar and sour cream, jalapeño, pizza,
honey mustard, which sounds weird.
Ugh.
No, no, no.
Oh, those taste like a mistake.
Someone screwed up on those.
That might be the worst one.
The Buffalo one was just too salty,
but that is the worst flavor.
I mean, this stuff is made
for 13-year-old gamers.
This is just made to sit and consume
while you're staring at a flashing screen.
Stimulus, stimulus, stimulus.
Like, I'm in awe of how intense these are.
[grunts]
Hey, Joe, can I try one
of those ranch Pringles?
It's quite, quite splintered.
Didn't survive the journey.
I like that. That's a good Pringle.
Need to get these over here.
Oh, God.
Buff – was it Buffalo ranch?
Yeah, I'm not eating these.
I'll skip those.
Hey, it's the Screamin' Dill Pickle!
Arr!
What is going, what is
going on on this label?
Chip is wearing goggles and a snorkel?
It would have been better
if the chip was just like
[yells]
You know when you go and
get a burger and the fries
and they put that wedge
of pickle on the side
and the pickle's touching
some of the fries
and then those fries taste like pickles?
This is a whole flavor of that.
Who wants that?
Over here we've got prawn cocktail.
Now, this is really popular in the UK.
For those who aren't
familiar with prawn cocktail,
there is no prawn in here.
What this is, is the sauce
that you would normally serve
with a prawn cocktail.
It's just a kind of
tangy, tomatoey Pringle.
And, personally, I'm a big fan.
Then we're moving on to this one,
which is paprika flavor.
In this menacing-looking black, fiery can,
we have hot and spicy Pringles,
but they're basically just Pringles
flavored with some jalapeño extract
along with some other peppers as well.
They don't smell too spicy.
Cheers.
I'm getting, like, a little bit of garlic,
little bit of tomato.
Not getting any heat though.
People insist on calling
things hot and spicy
and then make things that really
aren't that hot and spicy.
Next up we've got smokey bacon Pringles.
Personally, I love these,
but I will say if you eat one
they stay on your breath
for about two weeks,
regardless of how many
times you brush your teeth.
Then we've got some peri-peri Pringles.
Now, if you've seen the Nando's episode,
you'll know that, as a country,
the UK is obsessed with peri-peri chicken,
and Pringles have capitalized on that
with some
peri-peri-chicken-flavored Pringles.
According to the UK Pringles website,
you should also be able
to get steak Pringles
and Thai sweet chili Pringles.
But none of the
supermarkets that I visited
actually had any.
Now, in both the US and the UK,
you can get spicier Pringles.
In the US, they are called Scorchin'.
How hot could these possibly be?
Scorchin' chili lime.
Not that hot.
Actually –
yeah, no.
Instead of Scorchin',
our spicy Pringle range
is actually called Sizzl'n.
Sizzl'n. It's fun to say.
And it comes in a Kickin'
Sour Cream exclusive
or as an extra-hot cheese
and chili exclusive,
which unfortunately we
weren't able to find today.
It's sizzle time.
Sizzl'n sour cream is a strange one,
because sour cream is the
thing you're supposed to use
to, like, cool the heat down.
Definitely attack your tongue a bit more
than the hot and spicy ones did.
Still not, like, mind-blowingly hot.
Also in the US we got these wavy Pringles,
which look like they're just
straight ripping off Ruffles.
Classic salted,
applewood-smoked cheddar,
fire-roasted jalapeño,
sweet and spicy barbecue,
and something to do with
the video game high-low –
[sighs] "high-low."
It's something to do
with the video game Halo,
MOA Burger.
All this is for children.
This is all for children.
We might not have wavy Pringles,
but we do have rice fusion Pringles.
These are Pringles
which are made with rice
and inspired by Asian flavors.
Indian tandoori chicken masala flavor
and a Japanese katsu curry flavor.
We're supposed to also be able to get
Malaysian red curry flavor,
a Peking duck and hoisin sauce flavor,
and a barbecue teriyaki flavor.
The last exclusive Pringles
I want to talk about
are the original lightly salted.
Yeah. Perfect.
This is how potato
chips should taste like.
Yeah. Unfortunately,
Pringles lightly salted
equals normal everywhere else.
It's so bizarre.
It's like hair and no hair.
Why they made that choice?